[Music]
we've known about the idea of the
greenhouse effect since the 1820s but it
was Eunice Foote a women's rights
activist who first showed how it could
actually work in 1856 she used an air
pump to fill glass cylinders with
different gases and then tested the
effect of sunlight on them one is carbon
dioxide co2 the receiver containing the
gas became itself much heeded and on
being removed it was many times as long
in calling Fitz experiments suggested
that co2 and water vapor trap heat more
than other gases - and the potential
effects on our climate began to emerge
an atmosphere of that gas would give to
our earth a high temperature that year
she submitted her findings to an
American scientific society at their
conference she wasn't able to take
questions directly because someone else
presented her work for her and it wasn't
published in the Proceedings of the
Society another journal did end up
publishing her paper but it went largely
unnoticed
three years later Irish physicist John
Tyndall did more complex experiments
finding other greenhouse gases that
Rapides he went on to become one of the
founding figures of climate science
nobody knows if he'd read Yunus firts
paper but his own didn't mention her or
her gas cylinders at all no pictures of
Furth have survived and her contribution
remain buried for a hundred and fifty
years only coming to light by chance in
2010 when a retired geologist discovered
a citation of her work in an antique
science annual guy Stewart Callendar was
a steam engineer by day and an avid
collector of climate data in his spare
time by the 1930s he was collecting
temperature readings from 147 weather
stations around the world no one had
ever created the data like this before
and when he compared his temperature
readings to historic measurements of co2
he discovered a clear pattern calendar
saw that not only was climate change
it was at least partly down to the
burning of fossil fuels in 1938 calendar
presented his findings to a scientific
body but the idea that we humans could
influence something as huge as the
Earth's climate was still for many too
hard to believe it wasn't until after
the Second World War that the effect of
human activity on global warming at the
calendar effect was proved right in 1958
chemist Charles Keeling's colleagues
were studying the relationship between
ocean acidity and carbon dioxide until
then it had been thought that the oceans
quickly absorb most co2 taken out of the
atmosphere but that didn't appear to be
true healing had a hunch that scientists
had been under estimating how much of
the gas was actually over our heads I
was telling these people that the whole
field was pretty barely screwed up
atmospheric co2 readings had been taken
for decades but the data was unreliable
Keeling was convinced he could do better
and looked for a spot that was as far as
possible from the position of cities and
Industry he went to the middle of the
North Pacific 4000 metres above sea
level to the huge active volcano of
Mauna Loa in Hawaii if you had to pick
the spot anywhere which would have given
a representation of the whole world with
one single site mana law Observatory has
probably thought the best choice his new
data proved two things firstly it showed
that co2 goes up and down with the
seasons but if you zoom out from these
sores teeth you can see the second thing
that Keeling proved atmospheric co2 was
increasing year-on-year healing began
plotting his readings on a graph and the
ominously upward curving line the
Keeling curve was born but the mono
lower project faced challenges equipment
broke down and it struggled to secure
funding it was only through sheer
perseverance that the observatory kept
taking its readings
eventually awarded a National Medal of
Science for his work and today Mona Noah
is still the world's benchmark site for
measuring co2 it's now more than 160
years since unis foot suggested the
cause of global warming more than 80
years since guy calendar demonstrated
the planet was warming because of human
activity and more than 60 years since
Charles Keeling showed co2 was rising at
an alarming rate and here we are
you